Stephen hawking ist nicht nur einer der renommiertesten wissenschaftler weltweit gewesen er war auch ein großer visionär und hat auch durchaus
Kontroverse thesen vertreten und er hat auch verrückte experimente gemacht eines davon betrifft
zeitreisen denn hawking chance zumindest die möglichkeit
Nicht aus dass es zeit reisen geben können was ist also mit hawkings zeit reisen auf sich hat
Jetzt in unserer kleinen serie in loser folge in memoriam stephen hawking klicks. Im science fiction herzlich willkommen
Stephen hawking ist sich sicher in der zukunft werden wir in die zukunft reisen können und das ist eigentlich auch nichts besonderes
Wenn man sich mit der speziellen relativitätstheorie
beschäftigt da legt sich immer mit derselben geschwindigkeit
Fortbewegt ja ich weiß in verschiedenen medien ist das anders was aber mit der interaktion der photonen also der lichtteilchen
Mit den teilchen dort zu tun hat also eine pause darstellt also liegt hat eine unabänderliche
geschwindigkeit
299.000 792 458 meter pro sekunde das sind so rund eine
milliarde kilometer pro stunde da die lichtgeschwindigkeit aber unabänderlich ist muss sich alles darum verändern raum und zeit werden gekrümmt bei
hohen geschwindigkeiten führt das zu einem langsameren verlauf der zeit das heißt im umkehrschluss
außerhalb zum beispiel eines raumschiffes verläuft die zeit viel schneller das kann zb
heißen dass an bord eines schnell fliegenden raumschiffes ein jahr vergeht während auf der erde zehn jahre vergehen auf diese weise
Könnte ich in die zukunft reisen aber geht es auch zurück es gibt ja in der quantenphysik modelle die reisen in die vergangenheit
Ermöglichen allerdings nur dort es geht
um schwarze löcher die die raumzeit
So stark krümmen dass er am ende auf sich zurück gekrümmt sind doch es gibt ein problem ein wichtiges prinzip der physik
ursache und wirkung
Würde damit auf den kopf gestellt werden denn die ursache liegt demnach immer in der vergangenheit und die wirkung in der zukunft deshalb
Wagte hawking ein spannendes experiment, er veranstaltete eine party schickte die einladung aber erst danach auf
besonderes haltbaren papier ab dass also
jahrtausende überdauern würde nachfahren von uns hätten die einladung eigentlich finden müssen doch auf der party
Erschien kein einziger gast zumindest in diesem experiment konnte also ursache verschicken der einladung in der zukunft und wirkung
Partygäste in der vergangenheit nicht umkehren es spricht also einiges dafür dass es
zeitreisen in die vergangenheit nicht gibt wir hätten solche zeitreisende schon längst auf spiele müssen aber es gibt ja eine quelle die viel
effizienter in der lage ist zeitreisender aufzuspüren das internet und da hat sich ein forschungsteam daran gemacht dass nach
Zeitreisenden zu durchsuchen sie forschen einfach auf twitter nach ob es jeweils einen einzigen tweet gibt der das erscheinen des kometen izone
2012 heraus sagt oder die wahl von
Hornberg gollnow zum papst franziskus das ergebnis auf ganz twitter gibt es keinen einzigen tweet der einst dieser beiden ereignisse
voraus sagte sieht also schwer danach, aus als das höchstwahrscheinlich zeitreisen in die vergangenheit
Nie möglich, sein es scheint also so dass es wahrscheinlich
Im bereich der quantenphysik bewegung in der umgekehrten zeit richtung
Geben könnte aber für uns menschen das nie
Realität wird auf die neuesten erkenntnisse sind dazu bin ich gespannt wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema
Zeitreisen und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer wards erpressen
direkter link dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von kling zum mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und mitbestimmen was ihr bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter damit dafür auch
Draufklicken stephen hawking ist tot das war ja eine wirklich sehr sehr traurige meldung und da gibt es alles zum thema ansonsten bis dahin
bleibt dran